hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 1971 candidates series
it's a Bobby Fischer vs. Tigran
Petrosian and this is game 9 so some of
you have asked me in the previous video
how come they're continuing the match if
it's already five and a half to two and
a half in Fischer's favor well the game
the match isn't over because the finals
is not a ten game match the
quarterfinals and the semi finals were a
ten game match whereas the finals are a
12 game match so as the score is
currently five and a half two and a half
in in Fischer's favor there's still a
slim chance Petrosyan can get back into
the match or even win the match
if he wins four of the next games in a
row which you know no one pretty much
ever did against the Bobby Fischer but
okay I mean if there's a chance of why
not to give it a shot and it's very
interesting if you look at the first
five games of this match pretty much it
was it was like a match that was pretty
equal but it did seem like Pat Rosen had
the upper hand in this match and now
after only three games after the first
five rounds were now eight rounds have
been played it's it now the result seems
like Fischer is completely crushing
crushing Petros and in this match so a
very interesting matchup and it's very
interesting to see what pitocin has
installed with the black pieces against
Fischer in this game nine so let's check
it out
Fischer as usual with the white pieces
opens with E 4 we have e 6 the fringe
defense d4 d5 Knight to c3 so the
standard variation Knights the c6 and
now Fischer goes Knight to f3 we have
nice to f6 and now comes a captures on
d5 Adelaide exchange variation he
captures on d5 and now Bishop to b5
simply pinning the Knight Bishop to g4
we have h3 asking patrols and what do
you want to do with this Bishop and
petrosal simply captures Bishop captures
Queen captures so for the moment
Petrosyan gives up the bishop pair we
have Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to g5
a6 Bishop captures pawn captures and
Fischer's castles so this is pretty much
a textbook game for now
the position is basically equal black
has a bit of a stronger Center but he
does have doubled beep on CC points as
compensation he does have a semi-open be
file ID to use for his rook okay and we
have castles by Petrosyan rook F 2 e1
and h6 now ask me Fisher what do you
want to do with your Bishop Bishop to h4
was played Queen to d7 and now comes a
rock to e2 rook to e2 woods the idea of
perhaps doubling rocks on the e-file
patters and pushes a5 a5 preventing
Fischer from any expansion on the Queen
side and with this Petrosyan will try to
undermine officials Queen side points
with the rock using the semi-open B file
we have rook 81f Fischer doubles up on
the e-file as planned and now you could
probably counter this with rook 88 this
does seem to be like the most obvious
choice countering rook f28 is also
possible but that perhaps weakens your
King side a bit but as Petrosyan doesn't
really have the option of going for
4.com draw each lines he has to create
some imbalances in the position so he
simply moves the bishop back push up to
d8 what did this he now prepares to
continue with his plan but also by
playing this Bishop to the back rank his
rooks are now not connected which is
definitely not a great thing but he is
planning nice to e4 at some point to
exchange the dark square bishop so ok we
have b3 a Fischer is expecting of course
rook to b8 and also Petrosian has a very
weak c5 square so by playing b3 there's
a nice outpost for the knight on e4 so
Knight to a4 to c5 is definitely a plan
rook to b8 and now comes Knight to a4 as
planned
nice to e4 now there's a square
available for the night as the night
left c3 and also the knife from efore
nicely guards the c5 square now there's
a tension between the two bishops of
fischer exchanges them but should
capture some b8 rugby after sandy 8 and
now comes Queen to f4 Fischer would very
much enjoy pushing the f3 to kick away
this night from here and
then free the c-5 square for his own
night to be able to get there it's a
very nice square for the night Queen 2d6
Tigran doesn't allow this him he he
offers the trade of Queens which Fisher
gladly accepts Queen captures who have
pawn captures now improving the the pawn
structure in the center and now comes c4
by doing this Fischer was now allowed to
put this c4 pawn get rid of his backward
C pawn and of course you cannot capture
on c4 because your knight will be
hanging here so Knight back to f6 we
have looked to see one as Fischer would
very much enjoy opening the C file and
also you don't really want to capture
here as after your you're not gonna
capture with the pawn of course you're
gonna capture with the rook after rook
captures the c6 point is very weak and
it would be impossible to guard it for
example rook c8 you attack the rook with
the night rook c7 and then you simply
double up here and there's no way to
defend the c6 pawn so after up to c1
rook to b8 was played by Petrosyan we
have C capture some d5 now you have to
capture with the pawn because it's under
attack by the rook pawn captures and
then out comes f3 f3 a very nice move
that will take away these Knights D
squares from from the night also for
example look to e7 seems like a very
nice active move but it allows rook to
be 4
you want to keep your rook on the second
rank to always be able to defend your d4
pawn with rook to e2 for example if you
play rook to d1 now then rook to see it
and all the sudden black is the one
that's getting more active so after C
captors on d5 f3 by Fischer leaving his
rook here so now rook to be 4 doesn't
really make much sense and now we have a
knight to h5 so very nice move of course
f3 was a very nice move by Fischer as
well but you can't have everything you
have a firm grip on the e4 and g4 square
but now that Petros on tracks that tries
to take advantage of this as now you've
weakened the dark squares around your
King
so okay rook the c6 Fischer attacks the
d6 pawn we have nice 2 F for attacking
Fischer's rook rook to d2 and now comes
a rook to e8 we have pawn captures on d6
and now rook to e1 check Petrosyan
decided not to try and defend the the
double the d6 pawn rather he wants to
grab some activity King to have to
attack in petrosian's rook and now comes
rope to h1 we have King to g3 here
Fisher attacks but Rosen's night with
the king and now comes Knight to h5 with
check you could try something like g5
seems like a very nice idea but
unfortunately there's no way there's no
way to actually threaten the white king
here there's I mean if this rook wasn't
on second rank and then ideas like Ruby
g1 and captures here would definitely be
possible but one of one of one more
reason why you should leave your key
leave your rook on the second rank so
came after king 2g 390 to h5 would check
and now we have king to h4 Fisher
further goes deeper with his king and
attacks the night on h5 as well g6 until
now comes rook captures on d5 so Fischer
simply keeps gobbling up patrols and
spawns and patrols chances lie somewhere
perhaps in checkmating Fisher's King
which is currently not possible but you
know who knows what the future holds
rook to e8 you might you might think
okay let's try and defend this pawn but
here even a move like rook captures on
h5 captures captures would probably be
enough for Fischer to win this game he
would simply be up three points for the
exchange and there's a there's a past D
pawn I'm pretty sure this is enough to
win this game but okay after room d5
petrosyan will now try to give up
everything and simply you know give it
all in to try and checkmate Fischer's
king rook captures on a5 Fisher thinks
there's no danger here and he simply
continues gobbling up pawns our rook e
t1 and Knight to c3 and now comes Knight
to f4 we have King to g4 and now Knight
back to d6
e six now we have rook to e5 here
favorite offers the trade of rooks of
course
Petrosyan wants to do everything he can
to to avoid exchanging material because
if you if you imagine all of these
pieces are off the board
you can easily see that Fischer is up
three points and he would simply push
any of those three points and fast bones
to victory so here f5 with check Fischer
goes to g3 and now we have f4 with check
now of course you don't want to play
something like King to f2 to allow rope
to f1 with checkmate
so Fischer has to go to h4 King to h4
was played and now comes King to h7
playing something like g5 does seem to
make a whole lot of sense but after King
to g4 it's pretty much impossible to
continue this attack there's no way you
can make it with something like King h7
to g6 and then for example to push h5
really no way to do it let's say Knight
the g7 rook captures rook captures white
and simply breakthrough with h4 and
there's no way to checkmate the white
king anymore so King to h7 petrosal
tries to bring his King closer Knight to
e4 now there's no longer this tension
between the rooks and now rook captures
Knight is definitely a threat first g5
would check from Petrosyan now we have
King to g4 and now comes nice to g7 so
here Tigran is once again threatening
King to g7 followed by h5 checkmate and
Fischer has to do something to stop this
so it's very interesting Fischer needs
one more win to win this match and this
is move 39 of this game so they still
haven't reached time control and it's
very interesting of course to win this
match and win the opportunity to
challenge Boris Spassky for the title
you have to make it look the correct
move before move 40 before reaching 10
control or else you're gonna of course
run out of time so Fisher without
further ado simply probably he could
have played some other moves but he
doesn't want to get checkmate it and
he's up so much material so he decided
to play Knight captures and g5 so now
the time control has been reached and
the the material advantage is just too
great we have eight captures and now
rook captures any one rook captures
anyone and now King captures on g5 so
Petrosyan is now up a night but Fischer
is up five points
and the f4 point is a very weak point so
very soon it could be up six bones and
being up six bones is well that's like
two nights not just one night so okay
Knight to e6 would check was played by
Petrosyan we have a king to f5 and this
now comes rook to e - of course
Petrosyan doesn't think that this might
actually work he just probably wanted to
play anything to finish the game at
least with style rook captures and he
too was played Knight captor son before
which with check Fisher doesn't even
capture the f4 pawn we have King to e5
and here Knight captures an e2 was
played and after Fisher played a four it
was unformed 46 that Tigran Petrosian
resigned this game so there we have it
this is game 9 and this is the final
game of the finals of the 1971 candidate
series Bobby Fischer wins this with six
and a half to two and a half against the
former world champion Tigran Petrosian
and I would very much ask you to pause
the video here and check the link the
first link in the description below it
will take you to the original footage of
this exact moment when Fischer won game
9 so you can see the atmosphere created
by the audience there was so much
screaming so much applauding so much
people screaming Bobby Bobby so feel
free to pause the video and check it out
it's it's truly amazing but then of
course come back to this video so I'll
give you a couple of seconds to decide
whether you want to do it or not
so for those of you who did it
congratulations I hope you left a nice
comment on this video because it really
doesn't have all that much views or all
that many views I believe it's all that
many views sorry about that you are of
course an excellent subscriber and thank
you for that and thank you for always
being an excellent subscriber but yeah
getting back to this game of course
there's really nothing to do here it's a
night and night against five points
whatever you do Knight c3 perhaps you
want to stop these pawns simply King
attacks tonight
the Knight has nowhere to go you have to
go back check you move the King and now
you can simply push your point to
victory and there's no way to actually
grab the g2 pawn and the other points to
maybe start pushing your own F pawn
because there's simply no way to do it
there's no square
from which you could actually attack the
g2 pond so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you have
been enjoying the Bobby Fischer series
so far I would like to thank Mickey
Grammatik of Rodrigo Murillo Hector
Coronado David Guzman enhance Peter
where's for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and yeah we're probably gonna take a
little break from the Fisher series not
not too long ago break perhaps a week or
something and then we're gonna continue
with our Bobby Fisher story continue
tackling the entire world chess
championship against Boris Spassky in
1972 in Reykjavik how about until then
I'm gonna check up on some of your
suggestions to maybe cover something
I've been missing and there are a couple
of live events going on in the world at
the moment so in 1972 Bobby Fischer will
face Boris Spassky in Reykjavik but that
will truly be a while series as there
we're gonna have to tell a lot of
stories much more stories than actually
showing the games but you know such is
the way of of chess and YouTube and yeah
it's not that it's not that the Soviets
are just waiting to see what will happen
in Reykjavik pretty much after seeing
Fischer's magnificent display against
the marked Amano against bent Larsen and
against even Pete Rose and they pretty
much know what's going to be the result
in Reykjavik so they're not just waiting
to see they're actually preparing their
new champion because yeah even the
course no end
Petrosyan and all the all the players of
the old guard said that pretty much none
of the older players will have a chance
against officially in the future so they
started preparing their new champion so
well this is all of this is going on and
we're enjoying this for sure story there
is one champion getting stronger and
stronger in the shadows that is of
course Anatoly Karpov he's he is the one
that was supposed to challenge Fischer
in the future if you of course defeats
Boris Spassky you know but yeah that's
about it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon hopefully with some of
nice interesting content perhaps some of
some of the content that you suggest in
the comments thank you all and I'll see
you soon